[Music]
we're here married
nothing went wrong even my mother
behaved herself he set eyes on me for
the first time hello hello and I saw a
man who wasn't wearing a jacket nonsense
oh yes and trousers with amend in the
knee did you think then it was not so so
that girl actually I'm a little bit
scared what does his father do you mean
is he working class or one of us that's
more or less what I mean
you don't seem quite as happy as you
should something's bothering you flow
coming flow it's easy just point and
choose something about yourself little
delicate the sex manual says women are
like doorways men can enter through them
got a flirt how long have you in there I
thought I just lost your question damn
it
they all liked I'm feeling rather sick
what is it darling nothing you can't
change your mind
I really have to go we can never be
happy and it's all my stupid fault
have you actually forgotten that we were
married today
we're man and wife that will you promise
me
it's hopeless is it
[Music]